famous things as pac-man ghosts and a
hot myspace photo dog toilet it's
episode 26 of IMG drafts can kiss but
when people kiss a giraffe can be hidden
and - Coleman made GAMEOVER decorated
with classic videogame deaths on a
related note Luigi is a bad influence
this building is like oh and here's Star
Wars zeenite you know by Van Gogh's
Sergeant Pepper choppers are awesome but
this is a little much so let's go
smaller
you know miniature patty cherry tomato
exacto knife smaller snowmen can be
upside down
spongebob II halo II or plastered above
the ground like Spider Man and no no no
it's uh it's actually too late to use a
condom at this point but here's a real
three-story house accessible by an
internal three-story slide gift break
don't play with a sore loser because
sometimes this will happen and even
though cats can be ferocious the best
thing in the world is animals about to
sneeze
let's give break again when you cut
vegetables into thin slices and then
cycle through each slice in order you
have a movie moving through a cucumber a
pineapple or broccoli remember an IMG 18
when we fell asleep on our blackberries
well sit on this bench relax and after a
while walk away as a mobile
advertisement while you walk wears some
Mickey sneaks complete with ears or Toy
Story shoes with the trademark name
speaking of Disney deviant artists X
Arial has created inappropriate Disney
Princesses but if you prefer your ladies
delicious use a cheeseburger dress I
heard it comes from real cows beach cows
or upgrade to a Pokeball bra then
propose marriage dressed as Superman and
Jessica Rabbit but be sure to invite
Tweety Bird I know I know old people can
be scary really scary even when escaping
to montages in 1 IMG is ridiculous so I
refuse to show you gigantic women but
what the age
let's get char T this map shows American
dialects it's crazy big and detailed so
if you want to look at it follow the
link in the description but for instance
this pink line delineates where people
pronounce pen and pen alike but here is
something screwy can art get any
awesomer yes Facebook founder Mark
Zuckerberg is the time-travel twin of
King Philip the fourth of Spain and
Mario goes to Vegas to experience fear
and loathing but on facebook.com slash
Vsauce gaming summer showed us Mario's
worst nightmare and William asks how
many points is this word Polina
introduced soda on tap and Tim Ryan
showed us an iPhone bed and reading in
bed if you want to submit your own
favorite images and possibly get shouted
out on this show like us on Facebook
it's also a good way to let people know
that you are cool and know what is
important I leave you today with cats
sleeping in weird positions subscribe to
Vsauce for more and as always thanks for
watching